CHUMLEE: What you got here?
I've got a pair of
LeBron autographed shoes.
That's pretty cool.
JIM: These are actually
the wheat edition ones.
There the 2004
All-Star game ones,
and they're a limited edition.
I've never actually
seen these in person,
but they might be worth more
without the signature than
with it.
- I don't know about that--
CHUMLEE: No, I'm just joking.
JIM: The shoes are LeBron
James 2004 All-Star game shoes.
They're personally mine,
but I had them autographed.
The reason I'm
selling these shoes
is because I've had
them for 10 years,
and I'm hoping I can get
a lot of money for them.
They're a rare shoe itself.
The autograph's
rare, and I think
LeBron statistically will
go down as the number
one player in NBA history.
CHUMLEE: This is
pretty cool, man.
These are the Air Nike Zoom's.
How'd you get them?
Back in 2004 when I was a kid
I was at one of the Cavs games.
I saw him coming, didn't
have anything to sign,
so I took them right off
my feet, tossed it to him.
He signed them and
tossed them right back.
CHUMLEE: Sweet.
This is LeBron's first shoe.
They were actually afraid
to attach the name "LeBron"
to it at first because
they didn't know
how they were going to sell.
They didn't know how he
was going to do in the NBA.
But Nike decided to
give him $90 million
before he even played one
minute of NBA basketball.
18-years-old-- I
cannot imagine that.
It paid off for him though.
LeBron pushed
into the draft right
after his junior
year of high school,
but the NBA decided
he was too young.
Lucky for his teammates
though, because tickets
to his high school
basketball games were being
scalped for over $100 each.
So what do you want
to do with them?
I'm looking to sell them.
OK, how much did you
want to get for them?
I'm looking for about $1,000.
$1,000, OK.
The condition of the
shoe looks pretty good.
Looks like the autograph
is upside down.
I don't know how that's
going to affect the value.
If you have a little
out of hang out,
I'm going to call
a friend of mine.
He basically will look at this
autograph, tell me if it's real
and how much he
thinks it's worth.
Yeah, I can hang around.
All right, let me
go make a phone call.
I'm excited that the
expert's coming in.
Hopefully, he can
appraise it to something
higher than I expect it to be.
And I'm excited to see
what he has to say.
Now, I know a lot about
shoes, but I don't know
very much about autographs.
So I called my buddy Steven
to come take a look at it.
We got one of the greatest
player in the world shoes here.
These are his rookie shoes.
STEVE GRAD: Oh, cool.
And he only signed
one of the shoes.
It's right there.
STEVE GRAD: OK.
Meeting LeBron in
person is not that easy
and getting near him for
autograph seekers especially
or people just
wanting a picture--
it's not really that easy
to get near this guy.
So Chum, tell me your concerns.
Well, I don't
know if it's real.
And how much is it
actually worth on his shoe?
Because this obviously
wasn't LeBron James' shoe?
STEVE GRAD: OK.
Now obviously, I was
look at the exemplars.
The first thing starts
off here, and we kind of
see the same thing here.
And he just kind of goes
into this big mess here,
and it looks like he
came off it strangely
or just signed it abruptly.
Another example of his
signature-- once again,
he starts off here
as almost a 2 3.
You see here?
- Yeah.
This is a little sloppier,
and then he kind of
finishes the flourish off here.
It matches up pretty
good to the exemplars.
It's a little sloppier version.
I really don't have a problem
with the signature though.
And you think
it's OK upside down?
LeBron James--
super tough autograph.
So upside down on
a shoe, especially
a rare shoe like this--
I don't think it really matters.
Cool.
So how much is it worth?
Well, based on
everything here,
I'd put the value of this
right at about $350 to $400.
All right, well, thank you.
STEVE GRAD: Good
seeing you, bro.
Take care.
JIM: You too.
Just based on the fact
that LeBron so popular,
people really like that guy.
And the chances of you getting
his signature are pretty low,
and I think that thing
would fly off the shelf.
So we're looking
at about $200.
I think with the
combination of the rare shoe
and the rare signature I think
it's just too low of an offer.
Unfortunately, the rare
shoe and the signature
aren't going to sell
to the same customer.
I can go up to maybe $250.
JIM: That's not enough.
What's your bottom number?
JIM: I'd say about $600.
CHUMLEE: It's not
going to happen.
All right.
Thanks for bringing
them down though, man.
They're really cool.
LeBron James is a great
player, and it's not often
you get to see these shoes.
JIM: Thank you.
The offer of $200 is
definitely disappointing to me.
I'm going to take this
shoe back to Cleveland
and just hold onto it for
a couple of more years
until LeBron wins the
championship in Cleveland,
brings it home.
And then I'll see
what it's worth then.